well breaking news this is a source  apparently close to the tournament  speaking to the reuters news agency who  are reporting that novak djokovic's visa  has been revoked by the australian  government uh and issued with a letter  saying he will be deported  the reuters news agency goes on to say  that djokovic is finding a federal  injunction to stop the deportation so  this row over whether or not he is  entitled to be in the country is  continuing  so that breaking news a source  unnamed have to say close to the  tournament speaking to reuters novak  djokovic his visa has been revoked by  the australian government and has been  issued with a letter saying that he will  be deported